♫ Picture yourself in a world where there's no one else, ♫
♫ nobody anywhere. ♫
♫ A moment ago, there were voices and faces to look upon, ♫
♫ you can't see them anywhere. ♫
♫ Nothing more to say ♫
♫ and no one left to say it to, anyway. ♫
♫ Oh, listen to what I say. ♫
♫ Everybody can be somebody ♫
♫ and everybody is free to make a difference. ♫
♫ Everybody can be somebody. ♫
♫ Everybody is free to make a difference in this world. ♫
♫ Now picture a world where the people all feel their worth. ♫
♫ Children are everywhere. ♫
♫ Now there is a reason for everyone's time on Earth. ♫
♫ Wondering why you should care, yeah. ♫
♫ Nothing more to say ♫
♫ and only love can see us through, anyway. ♫
♫ Oh, listen what I say, yeah. ♫
♫ Everybody can be somebody ♫
♫ and everybody is free to make a difference. ♫
♫ Everybody can be somebody. ♫
♫ Everybody is free to make a difference. ♫
♫ You don't have to be a big celebrity ♫
♫ to feel the power, the power in your soul, no. ♫
♫ You don't have to be a big star on MTV ♫
♫ to realize that in your eyes is a view that only you can see. ♫
♫ Everybody can be somebody. ♫
♫ Everybody is free to make a difference in this world. ♫
♫ You can make a little difference in this world. ♫
♫ I can make a little difference in this world. ♫
♫ She can make a little difference in this world. ♫
♫ He can make a little difference in this world. ♫
♫ You can, I can, she can, he can, ♫
♫ we can make a little bit of difference in this world. ♫
♫ Everybody gonna make a little ♫
♫ little difference, yeah. ♫
♫ Talking 'bout everybody gonna make a little difference. ♫
♫ Everybody gonna make a little difference in this world, ♫
♫ oh yeah. ♫
(Applause)
Thank you so much.
This is a song that came about
because I think it's difficult to be in the world
and not be aware of what's going on,
and the wars and so forth.
This song kind of came out of all of that.
And I wrote a lot of happy songs on my first record,
which I still stand by,
but this has got something else in it.
It's called "Peace on Earth."
♫ There is no hope. ♫
♫ There is no future. ♫
♫ No faith in God to save the day. ♫
♫ There is no reason, no understanding ♫
♫ no sacred place to hide away. ♫
♫ There is no earnest conversation. ♫
♫ No words of wisdom from the wise. ♫
♫ There is no reconciliation ♫
♫ and no collective compromise. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth, ♫
♫ that's what we want. ♫
♫ that's what we all say. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth. ♫
♫ Yet, there in the hallway ♫
♫ lurks the ghost of war. ♫
♫ He wants more, and more, and more, and more, ♫
♫ and more, and more, and more, and more. ♫
♫ There is no darkness, no sunshine. ♫
♫ There is no great society. ♫
♫ There is no freedom without conviction. ♫
♫ There is no freedom to be free. ♫
♫ There is no heaven, no fire and brimstone. ♫
♫ There is no brotherhood of man. ♫
♫ There is no country, no one religion. ♫
♫ There is no universal plan. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth, ♫
♫ that's what we want. ♫
♫ that's what we all say. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth. ♫
♫ Yet, there in the hallway ♫
♫ lurks the ghost of war. ♫
♫ He wants more, and more, and more, and more, ♫
♫ and more, and more, and more, and more, and more. ♫
♫ The answer is ♫
♫ mutual-assured destruction, ♫
♫ a balance of power, ♫
♫ a weapon for everyone. ♫
♫ Mutual-assured destruction ♫
♫ bringing peace to everyone. ♫
(Trumpet sounds)
♫ Peace on Earth, ♫
♫ that's what we want. ♫
♫ that's what we all say. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth. ♫
♫ There in the hallway, ♫
♫ peace on Earth. ♫
♫ Peace on Earth. ♫
(Applause)